say that for grindr
i love that you think i have enough
self-esteem to be on grindr
what would my profile even say i'm gay
and disabled but i promise not to drill
on you until the third date there are
plenty of
that's ryan o'connell's character at
physical therapy in the netflix show
special after two emmy nominations for
creating and starring in a
semi-autobiographical show o'connell is
out with a new book that also has
similarities to his real life just by
looking at him is a novel about a gay tv
writer with cerebral palsy on a journey
of self-discovery and acceptance the
bush book is published by atria a
division of simon schuster which like
cbs is part of the paramount global
family ryan o'connell is joining us
right now first on cbs mornings good
morning ryan how are you doing
good thank you for having me this early
on in the morning check out my gay
smutty novel
it is very it is very smutty i have to
say it is take a look where they put the
uh the novel logo right out the gate
right out the gate we're not playing
around with this covenant don't read it
in public unless you want to blush a
little bit yeah and and we'll get we'll
get to the details in the books but
first i want to start off by by asking
you about how this book saved your life
because you made that statement it's
pretty profound why did it save your
life
i know i'm really dramatic i know i know
um well because when i started writing
the book i didn't intend to actually
write a novel i i wrote an exercise of a
thousand words a day it was sort of like
extreme sports writing edition and i
thought for sure i would hit a wall but
the thing that really really saved my
life through writing the book um was i
was really struggling with an alcohol
problem and i gave all the thoughts and
feelings that i was too afraid to admit
myself in the words of this character
elliot and it's sort of one of those
things like once you see honey you can't
unsee so um i got sober with writing the
book which like shifts 10 out of 10
would recommend
wow congratulations that's great to hear
ryan i you're very funny i love uh the
netflix show uh i love your first book
where does your humor come from when did
you develop this particular voice you
have
well when you grow up gay and disabled
in this society you realize you might
need a bag of tricks to get through it
so
like i feel like my humor i don't know
it's like i feel like i just look at
everything through all lens i i don't
know it's sort of it's been very innate
and i'm so glad i have it because i feel
like it's a superpower because i feel
like people see me and they're like
they're not really ready for this jelly
but i feel like my humor disarms them
and it's kind of more palatable you know
what i mean yeah so i feel very
fortunate to have it it
feels like a nice little weapon
oh no it looks like we might have lost
them a little bit there well i would
advise people pick up a book oh we got
them back
there we go
back like you never left
[Laughter]
oh you were gonna say something there it
is okay so what do you want people to
take away from this book
um i mean i feel like there's not really
a discussion around disability i think
people are pretty skittish around
disability i have a couple theories
about that i think uh if you age long
enough you might end up disabled which i
think people feel very uncomfortable
with um so i just i really
normalizes the experience of disability
and it makes people feel less skittish
around disability and i just feel like
more conversations need to happen around
disability um
so i just hope that they see this and
they feel like they're learning things
without being it being didactic i like
to cover the vegetables in tons of sugar
and i feel like there's so much sugar in
this book that you might get a cavity
but like you're gonna be eating kale too
you know what i mean
only a little bit of kale yeah and we
always heard it's good to eat your
vegetables congratulations on coming out
it's hot over the pandemic as well ryan
that was a big milestone no doubt about
it brian o'connell
thank you of course just by looking at
him goes on sale tomorrow we will be
right back we appreciate you ryan